[Music]
hey Sparky channel lost his channel with
like 188 thousand subscribers because he
was hacked do you think you can help
this guy hi thanks for attack our
Creator support team is already working
with the channel owner to get his
channel back appreciate the concern
Steven is a YouTube partner and YouTube
apparently told them though we've been
in contact with the Creator
Sparky Channel versus me a mistake I
haven't gotten any contact you know they
haven't contacted me at all I've written
them about seven times or so hey it's
been a month since you said you were in
touch with Sparky channel but I am in
contact with him and he says he still
hasn't been contacted by you and he
still hasn't gotten his channel back and
he's still being ignored hello hello hey
YouTube yeah a video of mine got falsely
claimed by a bogus email address and
their timestamp was actually a nerd city
video and I know nerd City he's a
youtuber and it wasn't him your process
to get my video back requires me to give
my full name address and phone number to
some random person that I know is
abusing your system and I really don't
feel comfortable doing that because I
know it's copyright abuse does your
system take into account provably false
copyright takedowns hi we understand
that you do not feel comfortable
providing your full information to the
claimant since the video you feel it was
claimed incorrectly unfortunately we're
unable to go around the process and the
information you're required to submit is
needed for us to process that
counter-notification
I hope that helps let me know if you
need anything else is there not some way
that I could prove that this was a false
take Donna I mean say for instance this
is a false takedown hypothetically how
would you Tube decide whether it is or
is not and take appropriate actions
against the copyright abuser I mean how
does YouTube actively enforce their own
policy on thou shalt not
false copyright takedowns hi YouTube is
aware of such and we're taking
appropriate actions for it
misuse of the process may result in
suspension of someone's account or other
legal consequences I hope that helps
clarify everything let me know if you
have any other concerns I am here to
help no it it doesn't clarify things my
question is how are you taking
appropriate action what is the process
you're asking me to provide my name
address and phone number to a stranger
that I have good reason to believe has
malicious intentions my question is how
do you protect me from abuse like this
using your own copyright system as a way
to fish for private info we understand
that you want to know the specific
actions that YouTube is imposing for
copyright abuse but well there's
currently no way to do that we
appreciate you taking the time to let us
know what you're looking for
besides honestly what's the worst that
could happen from a system that allows
any creators personal information to be
leaked online to anybody who wants it
YouTube your systems are being used to
Doc's creators tech lead and Matt Tran
blackmailed and threatened trend black a
commentary channel they said he had to
remove his criticism or he'd be doxed
and then they doxed him hi
thanks for sharing all of this contact
our team looked into this of course we
waited several days until all this
really blew over because we didn't want
to engage in any of it but we DM Trent
black after we sorted things out hi
Trent black welcome to YouTube decks
aboard ell I hope you're doing well
today the following is a prepared
statement to make sure we admit no
liability and your daxing blackmail and
threats
hey there trend wanted to reach out to
you directly with some updates on your
channel strikes we watched your video
sharing concerns about the situation so
wanted to start here with the hope that
you'll get this first we're sorry about
the frustration this is caught the Aires
Sophia you can't understand how sorry we
are
and we really appreciate you being
patient while we looked into it
oh yes we look far into it we started
investigating the copy strikes last week
and our team found that four of your
videos were removed without enough info
from the claimants that constitute a
complete and valid takedown notice those
videos have now been reinstated
hopefully you know that it on your
channel as well and you know I've heads
up those claimants may actually have the
opportunity now to provide more info on
this take that request and if you feel
they provide does compensate an
infringement the kind of could be
removed again so we've done nothing at
that point there a number of options the
next step I know we can cross that
bridge when we come to it
let us know if you have any questions
and uh feel free to continue to reach
out to us here with any issues you may
have thanks a ton for reaching out
firstly I wanted to say that my videos
are back up due to the striker releasing
them but that's not the problem here
the problem is that these traders of B's
the copyright strike system they knew
that the videos do not infringe
copyright violations in fact two of the
videos that were copyrighted used a
total of zero footage from that person
not a single clip or footage containing
or owned by that person was used this is
clearly abuse secondly they use the
copyright strike system to get my legal
name address and number then they use
this information to blackmail me into
taking down my fair criticism video and
after I said no they docked me I have
hard evidence including admitting it for
everything I just said boxing and
blackmailing me especially by using
YouTube's system to do it cannot be
tolerated this is a very scary
experience for me and my family and all
of my personal information is still
online my home address is online there
needs to be direct and percussions of
the two youtubers who did this I can
also send you evidence of the night
admitting to blackmailing and asking me
if you wish okay
we thought he'd get away with how and
again this is from our corporate
overlords to make sure that we don't
admit any guilt here cos oh we haven't
addressed your boxing and lack what
blackmail from other creators on the
platform thanks for the info trend we
look into the misuse of our copy
Rachel's very seriously even though we
can't tell you how we do it we do think
we're taking it very seriously we look
into it upto terminating abusive users
please continue to dispute claims you
believe are made in error more info on
copyright here hope this clarifies
so I've clearly showed you abusive users
can I expect termination of their
channels okay trend okay listen up they
love tour we can't guarantee but
everything still be subject for review
more here
okay ding is that okay look I'm just
just a sock puppet account
okay trap I can't do you think I have
power you think I have power I can't I
don't even have time to go to the
bathroom
okay I mean working like a dog in here
about going to every YouTube red account
and telling them exactly how to log in
when a lot of them don't even have their
computer turned on and you want me you
want me to go and solve a YouTube
copyright problem for you now this is a
ridiculous trim no learn your place
you just don't easily tiny over what
barely 60,000 subscribers you better let
me know if you have any more questions
have a nice day
[Music]